[Music]
the animated series is coming back yes
i'm sorry i'm so excited people
oh my god
x-men the animated series is making a
return by the way this is me recording
in the new studio uh let me know how it
sounds if it sounds better if it sounds
worse
let me know i'm very very curious got
sound blankets behind me
in front of me i got a green screen
behind me but sound blankets in front of
me
oh my god
oh my god
okay here's the thing man the reason why
i'm so excited about this right for
those of you guys who don't know the
reason why i'm so excited about this my
fans know this
x-men the animated series is how it all
started for me man that's what got me
into comic books was x-men the animated
series it's what started everything for
me right like had i never seen that show
as a kid i would not be the comic book
fan that i am right now right it's
because of x-men the animated series
that i love comic books it was one of
those things my dad and i used to watch
it like every saturday morning right you
guys remember the saturday morning tv
block x-men the animator series and then
spider-man right like spider-man
spider-man you guys remember that whole
thing that for me was my childhood man
my dad and i would sit down and watch
x-men the anime series because for him
it was reliving his childhood when he
read comic books for me it was a whole
new discovery and i loved it i remember
there was an episode that had black
panther in it you don't really get to
see him very long it's in the uh
sanctuary the two-part sanctuary episode
when magneto shows up in africa and like
black panther sitting on a rock
overlooking everything that's going on
so that was really cool but like i was
so curious about what all was there in
marvel comics besides the x-men and so i
started reading a whole bunch of other
stuff where i started reading like the
avengers and the fantastic four and
spider-man and so on and so forth and
then here i am 25 years later but x-men
that's what i always find myself going
home to right that's my book that's my
comic book
the x-men is my comic an x-men the
animated series making a return is so
awesome here's the biggest question that
i have man because
this could only ever go a couple ways
either it could be phenomenal and it
just hits us right into the nostalgia
feels and takes us back to a time when
the world was just so much simpler and
easier or
it could be disastrous
but nonetheless the the show itself you
know here's here was the thing a lot of
people get into this debate about what
was better like x-men the animated
series or batman the animated series
honestly they were really really good
but i always enjoyed the x-men more and
there were hallmark episodes that just
solidified the mythos right just
solidified x-men for me in terms of what
made the show so great right so okay
let's you know what let's let's we'll
talk about the other stuff in the room
around up whatever we gotta we gotta
first look at like moon knight right so
it's like moon knight exists cool bro we
gotta first look at like she-hulk all
right awesome whatever like we'll do
that on the room around up man x-ray
animated series is where it's at so
here's the thing when it came to this
show right there were there were
episodes that were just amazing so like
my all-time favorite was the four-part
series or four-part episodes beyond good
and evil that was great the funny thing
about that is that episode story is
actually based off a storyline called
the 12 in marvel comics where apocalypse
had basically attained like these 12
individuals who all represented
different aspects of like power and
their place in the cosmos and so on and
so forth and then he was going to
channel all their energy through the
living monolith basically this guy that
can channel like unlimited amounts of
energy and then channel that energy into
himself or maybe it was an x-man and he
was going to make x-man or host forms i
can't remember it doesn't matter anyway
it's based on the story called the 12
which is really cool apocalypse the
villain actually works alongside the
scrolls which is something you didn't
really see very often in marvel comics
but it was phenomenal right like the
days of future past i remember watching
the days of future past episode and i
was like god this is so cool like i
wonder if that's an actual story and
then like a few years later i remember
looking up days of future past stories
totally different than what you saw in
the episode right bishop doesn't have
hide nor hair in that story but it was
cool the way the way the episode played
out in comparison to the original comic
book story but it was things like that
right time fugitives right so like
bishop and cable basically have to team
up to like face off against apocalypse
with the x-men essentially like it was
things like that my entire childhood is
wrapped up in x-men the animated series
as far as one of my favorite all-time tv
shows go and so for me it's so exciting
to see the series come back because as
great as x-men the animated series was
there were so many stories that they
could have done that they never got
around to doing right most of x-men the
animated series the name is actually
kind of a misnomer the show itself
actually takes more stories from x
factor than it does from x-men x-men the
actual comic line felt a lot different
than the tv show did the x factor comic
by well really initially it was bob
leighton and then walter and louise
simonsen that's what most of the x-men
animated series is based off of right so
like the idea of of warren worthington
becoming the horseman death that was an
x factor right like the villain
apocalypse he was introduced in x factor
most of those stories are x factor
stories stories like days of future past
the introduction of cable things like
that a lot of that stuff's x-men but
most of the series is x factor and so
given everything that's happened since
that show went off the air there's so
many stories that you cover like could
you imagine an x-men the animated series
story basically involving like like
house of m right how are they going to
introduce the scarlet witch in a more
meaningful way quicksilver was there
right we saw a few things going on with
quicksilver which was kind of cool but
the show itself could go in some
phenomenal directions because marvel
comics has had some phenomenal x-men
stories since then right like the story
where the demon catholic showed up on
earth took over the body of quicksilver
and almost killed the world that was
amazing right i mean there's just
phenomenal stories that could be told
children's crusade right so like the
story of scarlet witch's kids uh billy
and and tommy and like who they're who
their real parents are their real
lineage their history the fact that like
wiccan is just this ridiculously op
character and the avengers tried to
imprison him because they were afraid of
how powerful he would become that he
would become as powerful as his mom the
scarlet witch and they didn't know if he
would be a hero or a villain characters
like matthew malloy matthew malloy was a
great character right it was the story
called the last will and testament of
professor xavier and basically you ended
up finding out somewhere along the line
professor x had discovered this kid that
just had like the highest and most
powerful mutant signature ever recovered
right this kid matthew malloy just drew
on energy from an extra-dimensional
source and while you never got to see
the full totality of what he would be
capable of if he reached his peak the
stuff we did see him do was kind of
stupid there was one point where he was
killed he resurrected himself from the
dead and i don't even know how a person
does that right the guy just resurrected
himself he could give himself any
superhuman power he could alter reality
i mean the guy was ridiculously op they
had to go back in time and stop him from
being born in order to find a way to
defeat him right i mean that was it that
was the only thing that they could do to
beat this guy i mean there's so many
great stories to tell in the x-men
mythos but what made the x-men the
animated series so great to begin with
were the interpersonal connections right
the the kind of of character-based
storytelling right that was all chris
claremont in the comics back in the day
and i'm sorry if i'm turning the
comments explain here i'm just really
really excited about this right so i'm
kind of i'm kind of all over the place
but when chris claremont took over the
x-men back in 1975 it was basically this
idea of telling stories from a
perspective that basically showcased the
the characters it was telling like a
soap opera so you had powers and you had
events and different things like that
but that in a lot of ways was a
background to the character development
right like building on the nature of
jean grey wolverine cyclops things like
that expanding who they are giving us a
much better perception of what they're
capable of it was phenomenal
storytelling you saw that play out in
x-men in the animated series had it not
been for the claremont run x-men the
animated series would either not have
existed or it would look totally
different so it was really really a
super impactful run the work that
claremont did there but looking at that
kind of stuff looking at the kind of
stories they can tell how the landscape
can change and adjust because now we're
not really looking at a situation where
it's kind of like well you got a
spider-man show and you got an x-men
show and they may or may not cross over
even though they kind of did but it
wasn't really that great of a crossover
now it's like the marvel cinematic
universe so it's x-men the animated
series falling in line with the overall
themes of the marvel cinematic universe
there's ample opportunity here and this
is one of the things to keep in mind
right like back in the day when netflix
first launched and he had like all the
the marvel shows that first launched on
netflix you had kevin feige on one hand
and you had jeff loeb on the other and
they were always butting heads right
like they technically reported to ike
promoter but like they were always
butting heads and that's why you saw the
netflix series that referenced the
events of avengers but it was stuff like
the event right the big green guy i mean
it was things like that it was never
like an actual tie-in to the marvel
cinematic universe movies it felt like
there was a kind of delineation there
right that's gone now fighty oversees it
all and so it's entirely possible you
could have like an x-men the animated
series that makes references to things
that are going on in other parts of the
mcu imagine if that had happened right
like imagine if we have x-men the
animated series that makes reference to
the events of like the first avengers
movie or like loki appears in it or like
the tva shows up and you basically see
that like the mobius mobius right like
owen wilson's character the animated
version you see in that show is the
exact same character from the loki live
action series he's just animated there
because the show is animated right you
can't have like a live action person
show up in an animated show it would
just look weird but like you know it all
takes place in the same multiverse
there's so many possibilities on the
what this show could do and that's what
i'm really hoping for i'm really hoping
that x-men the animated series captures
just the greatness of what made the show
what it was at the time combining it
with the current structure and format of
the marvel cinematic universe now we
also kind of have to tame our
expectations here because it's entirely
possible that's not possible right that
x-men the animated series was just
lightning in a bottle it was a great
show they produced a phenomenal concept
and it was awesome for its time they
could never duplicate that whether it's
because of the fact that they just don't
have any of the original cast voices or
the original canadian production team
isn't making it anymore whatever the
case happens to be that it just doesn't
quite feel the same maybe even we as the
viewer have grown past who we were at
that point in time and the show just
doesn't resonate and hit us the same way
regardless of what it is i mean i don't
know if that's the case because i still
watch x-men the animated series man and
that still slaps so like at the end of
the day i think that's entirely possible
right they're like it'll feel the same
but whatever the reason happens to be
that we have to go into this with the
expectation it could disappoint us i
hope it doesn't right i really really
hope it doesn't and i hope that it's
phenomenal i hope it's amazing and i
really think it will be i think that
disney lining up this show and bringing
this show to fans i think they recognize
the legacy this show created i think
they recognize the significance of x-men
the animated series for a lot of marvel
comics fans out there including myself
they recognize how important the show
was for us growing up and what it means
for us seeing it come out again in 2023
so that's my question to you guys what
are you guys hoping for with x-men the
animated series what are your fears what
are you excited about give me your
thoughts on this but with that being
said we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace